all right so let's get away from the
social sciences for a minute and jump
back to the business part because you
are at the stern School of Business so
let's talk about business you know I've
had a bunch of libertarians on lately
I've been talking a lot about capitalism
lately I know capitalism doesn't seem
cool to a lot of young people suddenly
socialism is really cool but in terms of
business one of the interesting things
that you've said basically is that
businesses can actually find more profit
just by acting ethically right there
seems to be this idea in America that if
you act unethically and you cheat the
system you're gonna win it you're gonna
win a lot of money or make a lot of
money or whatever but actually by acting
ethically they can have better bottom
lines correct yeah that's right so um
you know when I when I moved to stern in
2011 I had no interest in business I
just wanted to be in New York City and I
was able to get a temporary position
here and then soon after I got here
Occupy Wall Street broke out and
suddenly everyone was talk about
politics capitalism business so
something got really interesting and
I've learned a lot about in the last few
years and one of the things I've learned
is that there was an idea called
shareholder primacy that became very
popular in the 80s and the idea that you
know the business is owned by the
shareholders and your job is to is to
generate returns for the shareholders
and when you look at business that way
then your biggest cost is your employees
and the way what you need to do to honor
your fiduciary duty to the shareholders
is to squeeze the employees mm-hmm
please everybody squeeze the suppliers
pass on costs so if you have that view
then it's very hard to get business
ethics and you get all kinds of bad
behavior you get Volkswagen you get all
sorts of things um but that's a really
bad way of thinking about business and
what's been really interesting to me is
to see business as a human enterprise
business is overwhelmingly about
cooperation this is people I always
asked to my give talks what percentage
of your day are you spending competing
with anybody and what percentage you
spend in cooperating it's almost the
coverage and so once businesses begin to
think that business is a set a
relationship this is basically called a
stakeholder theory yoga you have to have
good relations with your customers with
your employees with your suppliers
those relationships need to be called if
you do that then over the long run they
help you out everything goes great and
people enjoy working for you so it's
once you get businesses to shifter once
businesses choose to shift to a long
term timeframe and think about
relationships ethics just follows flows
out naturally so that's interesting does
the morality part then come in and kind
of muck that up sometimes so you could
take when we had two years ago or three
years ago the big brouhaha over
chick-fil-a and their stance on gay
marriage
I assume that the owner I think is named
Dan Cathy if I'm not mistaken of
chick-fil-a felt that he was doing the
moral thing by giving some money to
people that were against marriage
equality obviously a lot of people felt
that he was doing the immoral thing and
protested and ultimately if I know
correctly they chick-fil-a's never been
more successful than they are right now
so injecting morality into it is
subjective and can create unintended
consequences right that's what my next
book is about the tentative title is
three stories about capitalism the moral
psychology of economic life is all about
how if you want to understand business
consultant' economists look at
historians of you know that's all
important but but actually a lot of it
is psychological and so our normal human
psychology makes it really easy for us
to cooperate and form these
relationships but there's interesting
things like for example the idea of
usury the idea of loaning money at
interest mmm-hmm now in a lot of
religions in Islam and Christianity long
ago well if I give you a hundred dollars
how can I ask for a hundred and ten
dollars back that's not fair and so
Ussuri was bad because it felt like
cheating felt wrong but you can't run a
good economy without you know without
availability of capital without loans at
interest so sometimes our moral
psychology makes trade possible
sometimes it interferes and like you
know uber everybody's talking about uber
and they are surge pricing you know oh
you're gonna charge me more when when
it's raining like the image of me that's
so unfair you know but like Americans I
feel like pretty much gotten that okay I
get but like the French and other
countries like oh no this is not fair so
you know so it's interesting the way
that morality can both block effective
business as in the chick-fil-a example
or
can it can sustain it and promote it
yeah so where does the government fit
into that then I'm gonna guess that
you're not huge into government
intervention but there's probably some
need for some of it to control the the
truly greedy people and the people
really with bad intentions right so this
is the fundamental question of politics
these days and they're couple but one of
the long-running ones is what's the role
of government and if you're on the Left
you believe in economic matters the
government should have a very active
role and if you're on the right you
believe it should not and I think the
most compelling view that I've heard is
the government has an essential role to
play in creating the platform in
creating the platform on which all this
activity takes place mm-hmm government
should not then be a player in the field
and so I spent three months in Asia last
year doing research for the book and so
Chinese capitalism is seen as very
successful until last summer stock
market went down well you know so
authoritarian uh you know it is
basically where the government sets up
the playing field and owns most of the
big companies and can change the rules
to favor its companies that's a really
bad game to be playing and lots of
people don't want to play so I'm not a
big fan of government being a player on
the field I think government must set
the rules set the standards run the
courts and you do need antitrust so I
mean there are a number of areas we do
need the government to play a role but
ultimately it comes down to how much do
you value decency sort of protecting
people and how much do you value
dynamism encouraging creative
destruction yeah so if you heard a
libertarian say well you know with
antitrust laws or with any of the stuff
that you're just making the government
bigger you know it's just sort of the
reverse argument but you would you would
say that you just somehow need some
controls on this stuff ultimately yes
but I would also say that whenever I
have sort of had intuition just from
like reading the newspaper and then I
talked to a libertarian they'll explain
oh no here's why that's totally wrong
and I'll talk to someone in the oh no
here's why that's what like we are so
limited and biased in our thinking
can't like these things are so complex
you can't just like read the newspaper
and figure it out and so and again you
need to bring people with different
views together with some norms of
civility to hash this out and so
universities should be where that
happens but you don't have I mean you do
have libertarians in the Economics
Department so that's good um but you
know outside of that you don't have the
kind of viewpoint diversity that we need
to figure out the most important
questions were facing like how do you
get capitalism working wells that we get
growth that is widely shared and then
we're all better off like that's we need
to figure out and because the
universities are getting so Orthodox not
good at it yeah so that's what I've
asked a couple of my guests that I've
had on lately like your own Brook from
the Iran Institute I haven't I mean does
capitalism just need some better people
to sell the ideas the ideas have become
uncool there's a you know as I'm
discussing this issue there's this
feeling it's you talk about Catholic it
feels old and antiquated but if we were
at a Bernie rally and you started
screaming about socialism everybody
would be thrilled that that's a real
problem that's right so um so capitalism
has always had certain problems and when
I say capital is what I mean is just a
free-market society mm-hmm they're
basically means a production are not
owned by the government generally and so
you have to keep keep separate whether
the government plays its heavy handed
role and then the question whether
there's a safety and a lot of people
confuse those two so everybody believes
there should be a safety net so
everybody like Scandinavian capitalism
and they think that Scandinavia
socialist and it was briefly but the
socialism part didn't work very well but
it was incredibly inefficient they had
huge budget deficits so they were able
to shift to a very free-market society
with a really good safety net in which
government has a role as a right if you
keep those two apart then you can get
people to say okay yeah we do need to
give people security and the left is
correct about that in America people
work with their job because they lose
their health insurance and so we're
supposed to be this nation of
entrepreneurs and risk takers we're all
afraid of losing our health insurance
you know nobama care has helped that but
in Scandinavia I here go in there next
is then yeah people are happy to quit
their job and try something new because
the safeness so good that they're not
worried so basically that's the the
trade-off that they they pay very high
taxes
but the safety net exists and then
they've sort of separated that from how
businesses are able to operate yeah
that's right you have to have a dynamic
business environment you have to is in
this world if you don't you're France
you're Italy you're going down there I
don't really see much a future for
southern Europe so you have to have a
dynamic business environment but
capitalism always has creative
destruction the reason why productivity
goes up and up and up is basically we're
able to do more with fewer workers and
so people get fired that's the way we
make progress but you can't just fire
them and leave them there and in
Scandinavia they do a lot of job
training they take care of them so I
think there are a lot of forms of
capitalism scandinavian capitalism is
usually held up as the best one ours has
problems and you know this this election
should be a time that we talk about so
I'm glad you brought up the election
because that's exactly where I wanted to
go right now so how do you take some of
these principles that you're talking
about morality in business and happiness
and business principles and ethics and
all of these things so let's go to
Donald Trump first because I don't know
how many of those words fully describe
them appropriately I guess it would
depend on who you're listening to what
do you make of well you know let's just
go to the business part of Donald Trump
first depending on who you listen to
this is either the greatest businessman
ever or if you listen to some other
people they'll tell you well he's been
in bankruptcy this amount of times and
he's cheated the system this way and
that way and the other thing what do you
make of him as a businessman before we
get to the politics part I don't know
that much about his biography my sense
is that he's not um he's not what you
would really say he's not a great
businessman what I mean is you know if
it was somebody who'd built a company
ran it made all the management decisions
faced crises um you know so if we had a
really know I've met number of CEOs
they're usually they got that high they
usually have good people skills good
analytical skills so if we had it you
know a CEO type it was also had some
compassion and if we had a good CEO type
I that's kind what we need like our
nation's really screwed up really
inefficient we need somebody to kind of
kick us in the ass you know Mitt Romney
could have been that like private equity
is all about you take an inefficient
thing you kick in the ass you make it
efficient so the best Mitt Romney from
when he was governor you know that guy
could have actually been what we needed
but we got was a Mitt Romney who went
through the conservative shredder uh-uh
wasn't anybody that I would
so um so I wish we had somebody like
that now Donald Trump as I understand it
like he said just a branding machine he
he inherited money he puts his name on
things but he didn't build those hotels
he did maybe he did some of it so I
don't think that Trump has has shown us
great the kind of business acumen
experience that we need Trump is
extraordinarily illiberal and uncurious
those are two traits I really don't want
in a president so I'm extremely alarmed
by the possibility that he could be our
president I think it would be a disaster
yeah you know it's funny because I'm
conflicted hit on him at least one level
which is that I'm so against the PC
stuff that I do like I do like that idea
right I like that concept he's breaking
through this being great I mean it's the
only good thing about a trump presidency
is the PC stuff right and yet ironically
I absolutely recognize this is the same
person who threatens to sue reporters
all the time so that that sort of goes
to the lack of a it do you think there's
a real lack of a moral compass there um
oh yes I do with Trump um but you know
it's interesting do you want a president
with a very strong moral compass and
here it's complicated I mean Jimmy
Carter very ethical man won't lie to you
and not an effective president um Bill
Clinton Slick Willy much moral compass
but I think a much more effective
president so you know I think
Machiavelli was right about we don't
want our leader our leaders we don't
want them to be Saints they you know
leadership is incredibly hard job being
the president is an incredibly hard job
um you want somebody's prepared to make
very very hard decisions too sometimes
even I mean I want to say break the law
but um you know they can't always play
by the rules yeah well you know so okay
so Hillary Clinton you know I'm not
there's no problem there I'm not
concerned that she's too ethical I don't
want to criticize her on that I just
want it you know cuz like I wish I
didn't have to vote for her but I just
think foreign policy and I think she can
handle it Trump can't and so I'm voting
for ya so that's interesting because a
lot of people I think are there with
Hillary there's a sense of this burn the
system down thing whether it's coming
from the Bernie people or the Trump
people and for most of the people that
are in but
Queen they're just saying this is this
is the best one we got and it's not
great but it's probably not that far
from Obama and that's even people that
like Obama and dislike Obama that just
want the system to exist that that's a
that's kind of very uninspiring huh
it's yeah so yeah I think that's where
we are another thing the other thing I
would add to this conversation about
politics is that voting for president
especially is not a practical thing it's
not like people are saying which one
will get me better tax rates and which
one will do more for me you know I mean
for the county you know regulators owner
we do that but president is it is a
quasi-religious position he's the high
priest the American civil religion and
so people aren't practical it's an
express event and this is why I think a
lot of people are voting for Trump even
a lot of conservatives now Trump if
you're a conservative
you don't want radical change like you
don't want somebody's going to just
knock everything down that's so
unconservative but a lot of people are
frustrated a lot of people are mad at
Obama right on the on the right so and
this is the big problem democracy this
is what I think a lot of Americans don't
realize the founding fathers hated
democracy they did not want a democracy
they read Plato Plato there's a mazing
article by Andrew Sullivan
on how we're following the path Plato
laid out about how countries veer into
tyranny and democracy is the step before
tyranny the founding fathers were afraid
that a demagogue can appeal to passions
and if you have a democracy the people
get to set everything up so we have a
democracy they gave us a republic but
over time in the progressive II area we
changed a lot of things about voting
about the Senate all sorts of things to
go from republic to more of a democracy
and that worked okay in the twentieth
century now you know if Trump wins it'll
it'll be the worst fears of the founding
fathers right so I did a video a couple
months ago on Trump and I basically said
what I fear is that he doesn't care
about any of our societal norms or even
how the government works and you know
that we have three branches of
government and the executive branch is
only one branch that signs stuff into
law and other people have to write and
another people have to decide whether
it's legal but a lot of people basically
were giving me [ __ ] on it basically
saying well those branches will
keep him in check but do you think when
it comes to someone of that big that
type of demagoguery that once you allow
that that then it really rattles the
others to their core on top of the fact
that he then would select Supreme Court
justices etc oh yeah
no that's right I mean we really could
be facing a constitutional crisis
and if you just look at the things say
that Ronald Reagan did to get a right or
they rencontrer deal George Bush had all
these signing statements Obama has done
so much by executive Fiat and these are
all like people who were like decent
responsible presidents they were found
ways to get around the law Trump was no
respect for the process and this is this
is you know once you believe that the
ends justify the means um that's the
that's the big step on the road to hell
so you know Trump has no respect for
process you could try it he would try to
make all sorts of things happen who's
gonna stop him I mean he could pack the
courts you know who knows what he could
do yeah so is that is that a huge
failing of President Obama then because
look we've basically been as I saw just
this morning you know he's the
longest-serving president ever at war we
still don't have congressional
authorization to be in Iraq right now
you know they they find little ways to
get around it he's done a lot via
executive action now yes george w bush
did a lot but when barack obama was
running he said that he shouldn't be
allowed to do it
obamacare he said you know we're going
to put all the proceedings they were all
going to be on c-span and it'll be
transparent it wasn't if you like your
health insurance you can give but it
wasn't now obamacare may basically be
fine that for other people to decide but
that the ends justify the means that's
sort of the way they all operate right
well that's right so the first principle
of moral psychology in the righteous
mind is intuitions come first strategic
reasoning second so once you know what
you want what end you want to reach you
then employ all your powers of reasoning
to get there so whatever party does not
control the Senate is adamant about
nothing filibuster and you know we need
the filibuster and then as soon as they
get power damn that filibuster you know
we the minority party is stopping us
from doing anything right so and that's
exactly what the Democrats did by the
way
that's right that's right and so same
thing with executive power so when the
other party has the presidency we need
limits on executive power and then when
they get power than they want no limits
and that's all been within the realm of
sort of like reasonable politics and so
if Trump comes in we're in like three
standard deviations beyond anything
we've ever seen and yeah it could be a
disaster what role do you think the
media plays in all of this because I try
to talk about the media you know the
media doesn't do this anymore
they don't do long-form conversation
really let you get to an idea they put
on representatives of campaigns they put
on former campaign advisers CNN
literally puts on super-delegates as if
they're somehow nonpartisan how do we
negotiate what the media is even telling
us yeah so there's two interesting
things that I from up the reading I've
done on is one is that we're just back
to where things that used to be so that
early days the Republic all the
newspapers were part of it and they were
nasty and they were full of lies so we
had a temporary period from the 40s
through the 70s when we had three
networks and everybody got their news
from these responsibles so that was the
anomaly in a sense we have to remember
that was the unusual time and so was
just sort of back to where we were so
that's partly true then there's a sense
in which we're in totally new territory
because of Technology so once you get
cable TV and then you get the rise of
these partisan shows on cable TV and
micro casting now one of our worst
cognitive sins is confirmation bias we
actively we reach out to confirm what we
already believe and so beginning with
cable TV all the way through the
internet it's made it so easy to confirm
and where it gets really alarming to me
is social media
I think this or the mainstream media is
less important to this social media is
something new because we're all really
really concerned about reputations and
the older media didn't impact but social
media you know what I hear is that
students like they're you know they're
on their Facebook page like they're
afraid to like something that they like
because they'll bits slaughtered oh yeah
so we're all it's like you know it's
like we're all living in East Germany
with you know with like the Stasi
looking over our shoulders and we're all
afraid to speak honestly so that I think
is more social media than the media
broadly construe
yeah and then of course there's people
just getting media information and news
from sources that they believe in and
that doesn't help either right that's
right that's right so the so we have we
have certain intellectual or cognitive
proclivities that are bad for democracy
bad for self-governance and our
traditional liberal institutions I mean
classical liberal institutions we're
sort of to guard against that and rule
of law trial by jury there's all sorts
of things to sort of you know restrain
our excesses and I think the modern
technological environment is again it's
like injecting vast amounts of
amphetamine and cocaine into us we're
all like you know jumping around like in
this new environment and you know I I
kind of hope that in 10 or 15 years
we'll understand that and we'll give our
kids will all have media training and
we'll have ways to sort of insulate them
from the fear of you know so we might
figure this out but for now it's kind of
whipping us all around we don't know
what's going on man so it really must be
such a fascinating position that you're
in
you're so around young people you're
around the the technology that they're
using obviously you're you're on Twitter
and all these things and yet you're
really doing the long game here and yet
you're around so much sort of short game
craziness how does that work for you
when you're trying to find happiness in
all this oh it's actually thrilling I
mean I'm very lucky in that um you know
I I kind of took some risks to start
speaking about this stuff and nothing
bad happened to me so I came out I
pointed out that my field social
psychology is is all on the left this is
damaging our research in some ways and
to my fields credit nobody attacked me
like pizza I'll heal maybe you're right
and so I mean I took some risks early on
but it like it's worked out very well
for me yeah
and now I've been doing it more and more
and like I keep going further and
further and nothing bad is happening um
so you know it's actually I feel like
huh you know I took some risk and it
paid off and then I get to like think
about all this interesting stuff and I
get to talk but like I I you know I just
love learning multiple fields so like
you know I get to learn about what's
going on with the media like you know
I'm now reading you know Plato and the
founding fathers like wow it's you know
so it's it's a gigantic sociological and
psychological puzzle and it's really fun
to figure
yeah so sort of you're providing cover
for other professors and faculty members
that just are afraid to do it as you
said we're right when we started you're
getting a certain leash here because of
coming from a business school that they
just don't have so you're really you're
like the front line on this and you're
the hope is that you can you know break
a wide-enough hole here that enough
people will come through with you yeah
but I don't want I mean uh you know I I
sort of stepped out in front in my field
in social psychology and then when I did
that I was then joined by some other
social psychologists we put a paper on
this so I've got five or six we're the
close allies Lee Justin Phil tetlock
Jerry Crawford Joe Duarte so we did this
in social psychology and then we heard
from you know a grad student in
sociology Chris Martin and then a law
professor Nick Rosencrantz and so we
formed heterodox Academy and then now if
you go there we have about 25 members
and next month we're going to open up to
any professor any person with a PhD an
academic a point will be welcome to join
we want to create a network of hundreds
and hundreds of people and we expect and
hope most will be on the Left we want
the liberal left and libertarians and
conservatives in same we all support
viewpoint diversity and potential grad
students if you come work in this
department there are four of us here in
the department who support viewpoint
diversity so don't worry you won't be
discriminated against so we think
because it's an emperor's new clothes
situation we think that now there's a
lot of us we can create a space in which
young people can come out and say what
they think that's what well yeah I'm
curious do you get pinned sometimes as
somehow a right-wing maniac because
that's one of the things I find if I
talk about this stuff I always say I'm
on the left that's why I'm talking about
the left I never I think only once in my
life I've never voted for a Republican
in a big election I think only once in
in a minor election so I was not gonna
say this right yeah so because of that
though I'm trying to police my side but
do you find that people pin you that way
um you know on the internet I'm gonna
get google alerts about my name and so
yeah you know once a month somebody
refers to me as a conservative but then
other book with nice is others will that
I could read my books you know they'll
write back because they know it's not a
conservative you know he's if anything
often people say I'm on the left I'm not
on the left anymore
but you know but but no I mean I'm well
enough known and people read my books so
like most people know I'm not a
conservative but I gotta say you know
this like just the last six months and
the campus stuff and the free speech
stuff is making me read a lot more
classical liberalism yeah I mean I feel
the same way I said to you right before
we started I mean I only started to show
this version of it in September you know
that's not that long ago and then
suddenly just some of these things that
I had percolating all hell started
breaking loose in here we are that's
right
in fact so you know it's just so current
so I was just reading so Deirdre
McCloskey it's wonderful economist at in
Chicago she has a new book out which why
you know bushwa quality and so she did
not just reading in the Wall Street
Journal her article and so she has this
great quote from Adam Smith I heard this
before but it's like here it is here's
it for Madison allowing everyman to
pursue his own interest his own way upon
the liberal plan of equality liberty and
justice like what's wrong with that like
that's pretty good right that what we're
supposed to be doing and that fits that
that's the part that I want to implore
for these for the social justice warrior
crew all of the justice that you want
fits within that you know what I mean it
fits within allowing people to express
their views and if you if you show them
your good views they will beat their
crappy old actually racist views instead
of just screaming racism at everybody
that's right
so um so a couple of maybe maybe I can
take some turn to put out a few means if
you guys isn't super funny or a lot of
your audience is students other students
yeah we I mean this is on the internet
so they're young yeah okay so two things
so one is I hope students and people
just start saying much more often you
don't get to tell me what to say or you
don't get to tell me what to wear and
this is what's so illiberal these campus
trans people say you can't wear that you
can't say that you can't do this like no
you don't get to do that so that's I
think is helpful idea and the other is
that what I really hope will happen is
that student groups on every college
campus in America next fall will push
their student government to hold a vote
I want them to be about on every college
campus are we a safe school or a
dangerous school if we're a safe school
that means we take steps to protect
people from hateful ideas we don't want
people to be upset by ideas that they
find offensive and we will have
bureaucratic and administrative
procedures well trigger warnings with
safe spaces we will protect people from
upsetting ideas that's a safe school
dangerous school says no you can't make
threats that's against the law and if
somebody and you know repeated stuff can
become can be bullying so you know there
are some limits here but beyond that no
no people say what they want and we
don't protect people from ideas you're
grownups and so I don't know how that
law play out but imagine imagine that
that let's say University of Chicago and
the University of Virginia those are two
schools that have really strong
traditions of free speech that they
voted to be dangerous schools what would
happen to their applications next year
it would go through the skyrocket I
think I hope right that's correct
and what kind of people would go there
it would be people a little bit tougher
who aren't so fragile so those two
schools would then have cultures that
aren't so vindictive and sensitive and
it'll be a lot more fun to go there and
there would be a flourishing
intellectual climate because people
wouldn't be afraid to speak so please
UVA students Chicago students if you're
listening yeah well listen I absolutely
I'm gonna spread those messages as far
as wide as I can I guess final thought
on this and I think I know your answer
you're probably a big proponent of
tenure correct no it's complicated um I
don't know um in general and working
this book on capitalism there's a really
important principle which is that we
need to have a world full of feedback
loops and so if someone does their job
badly they need to suffer or be fired
eventually if a business doesn't give
some people want it goes out of business
but in government we don't have those
feedback loops so government agencies
can treat you badly
year after year nothing happens mhm so
since I'm talking about that in my book
and I got to say well you know in tenure
we don't really have feedback loops I
mean there's a little bit of post-tenure
review
so so there are reasons why we would
have tenure but I think we have to have
vigorous and real post-tenure review
right in an issue I don't have a strong
opinion but I do believe that there
should not be guaranteed lifetime
employment ever anyway it has to be
contingent on how well you do your job
well look at that you just took a
position that doesn't necessarily ensure
your future well-being so that that's
how I know you're a man of your word
thank you well listen it's been an
absolute pleasure talking to you and
what's nice is that you know we do so
much about this up and it sounds so
depressing for the future and we think
things are spinning out of control but I
think you gave this a nice spin and this
is what people want to realize that that
we're winning and there's a chance here
so I really appreciate you coming on the
show it's a great pleasure time all
right and for you guys for more on the
work that dr. heit does check out his
website Jonathan hi calm all right
thanks doc Academy org